[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce livre où une fois
n'est pas coutume on va parler de
crevette avec mon invité Maurice d'cord
bonjour bonjour alors on va parler de
crevette mais la crevette c'est pas
celle qu'on mange c'est le nom de de
l'un de votre de vos héros Léon crevette
Léon crevette crevette puisque ce sont
des des polars c'est des enquêtes de
crevettes et bacardie euh on va raconter
un peu comment ils se sont rencontrés
dans un livre qui s'appelait qui était
le premier tome de de ce de ce duo qui
s'appelait tantou mergou euh qui sont
crevette et Bacardi alors crevette Léon
son prénom est un commandant de
gendarmerie détaché dans une unité de
police judiciaire voilà ça c'est ça
existe ça vraiment oui ça peut ça peut
exister c'est qu'il a à la fois flic et
gendarme quoi absolument toute façon
maintenant ils dépendent tous du même
ministère mais il est détaché dans cette
unité et donc il a il a la
responsabilité du du service l'autorité
d'un d'un commissaire commissaire ouis
et lors d'un
meurtre assez atroce où la le tueur
enfit la tueuse tag tantou mergo sur le
voilà alors ça c'était le le premier le
premier de de ces polares de de de ce
duo et il se trouve que il y a il y a
l'autre héros qui s'appelle Bacardi
Bacardi alors il a monté un truc assez
extraordinaire ou à sa retraite il a
décidé d'être écouteur des personnes
divorcées où en passe de lettres il
s'est dit qu' après tout t ces gens-l se
retrouvaient seuls après leurs amis les
fuyaient donc c'est pas un psychiatre un
psychanalyste il les écoute
et ça entreprise Fran qu'est-ce qu'il
faisait avant avant il travaillit dans
les assurances c'est ça les assurances
le parapluie avec le parapluie vous êtes
toujours couvert enfou pas mal et donc
il a trouvé ce job formidable et dans
dans to Bergot on va s'apercevoir qu'il
y a en effet des meurtres en série et et
que ces meurtres atteignent souvent des
gens notamment des femmes qui sont venus
le consulter hein c'est ça voilà c'est
que c'est c'est comme ça que ça démarre
et c'est comme ça qu'ils vont se
rencontrer ils vont se rencontrer et
après quelques quelques on va dire que
quelques
spiritueux onont sympathiser voilàou al
voilà il faut dire que je dis je dis on
va pas parler de gastronomie mais si un
peu parce que
euh vos deux héros crevette et Bacardi
donc le le le flic et le psy si on peut
dire euh ils aiment bien la bonne chair
le l'alcool quoi enfin le le le le repas
est un truc important chez eux c'est
c'est important oui oui c'est ce sont
des rencontres bistronomiques comme je
dis puisquils ont ils vont instituer un
déjeuner hebdomadaire au bar d'esport
alors le bar d'esport c'est un peu
limité au buf bourguignon mais dans dans
certains livres notamment le le dernier
l'affaire des flambaux Noirs ils vont
ils vont égrainer toute la gastronomie
possible imaginable dans dans un
restaurant qu'ils vont découvrir dans
serant qui est tenu par des Belges non
par des Belges oui
nul n'est parfait mais bon alors c'est
vrai que les les duos c'est un souvin
classique he du du du du Polard
évidemment on pense en vous lisant un
peu à son n tenu et
Berrurier c'est une filiation que je je
revendique oui sans problème mais on
pourrait avec euh je sais pas chez Fred
Vargas par exemple al ça c'est un
compliment en plus hein c'est non mais
il y a il y a un peu un duo re a il y a
un critique qui m'a mis ça oui entre
Adamsberg et puis son son commandant son
commandant ouais absolument hein c'est
alors il y a il y a tout il y a tout le
commissariat évidemment mais enfin il il
y a quand même un duo important et c'est
vrai que oui il y a peut-être il y a un
critique qui vous ait comparé oui qui
qui avait cité Fred Vargas qui m'a fait
ça fait très plaisir effectivement ou
c'est pas mal aussi c'est bien ah oui
mais je revendique alors pour faire
genre je dis que je revendique les
auteurs en art odiar Boudard Frédéric
d'art d'accord plus bien sûr l'ange
tutellaire le maître a pensé qui est
snon mais simnon c'est plutôt pour
l'atmosphère voilà oui d'ailleurs il y a
des références à à
simnon je sais pas si c'est vous qui le
dites ou si c'est lui qui le
revendique le le commandant crevette
enfin je sais pas si on dit commandant
si si command commandant
euh un de ces héros c'est c'est en
effet c'est c'est en effet le le héros
de simnon c'est dire méigré le flic
bourru il dit voilà si je devais on
devait me comparer à à quelqu'un ça
serait maigré hein flic bourru qui a
affecte l'air d'être un gros lourdau qui
n'est certainement pas en tous les cas
et au fil des enquêtes ça se ça se
vérifiera vous parliez de commissariat à
l'instant est-ce que je compte faire
également au fil des des histoires que
je que j'écrirai c'est de de l'étoffer
ce commissariat d'avoir de nouveau de
nouveaux personnages récurrents oui
absolument oui alors donc le le premier
tome c'était tontom mergo on l'a dit
c'est là où où se rencontre crevette et
bacardie ensuite il y a eu le secret des
mes du Tridon rouge alors là c'est
des des meurtrre de de jeunes femmes oui
euh et avec un avec un un tueur letttré
puisqu'il met des des citations latines
il met des citations latines et surtout
lorsque les
ENF lorsque les mes du Trident rouge se
réunissent voilà c'est une secte hein
voilà c'est c'est une secte il déclame
sur l'air de la belle Hélène deofanbach
alors je me suis amusé à
réécrire la présentation des le défilé
des rois voilà oui parce que c'est oui
je suis euh le roi menéas et cetera en
le Bou bouillantachile et cetera euh
évidemment
euh il y a il y a il y a il y a
évidemment de enfin ENF citation latine
c'est c'est intéressant c'està dire que
je dis pas que je dis pas que les romans
sont datés mais il y a il y a une
culture don don disiez parler de Boudard
de d oui c'est une culture de ma
génération certainement génération oui
c'est vrai que les les j'ai j'ai lu là
ce matin qu'il y avait en je crois en
Italie un un lycée qui se créait où on
enseignerait qu'en latin et qu'en
grec c'est le retour des humanités mais
ou je sais pas s'il y a plus grand grand
monde aujourd'hu candidat ou touberg
d'ailleurs c'est aussi bah c'est un
cantique hein ah oui oui c'est Saint-
Thomas Daquin qui a qui a qui a écrit ça
effectivement oui alors le le dernier
paru on va on va peut-être parler un peu
plus de celuilà c'est c'est l'affaire
des des flambeau noirs
euh le début c'est un propriétaire de de
bateau de pêche
heinou pas un armateur oui un
propriétaire oui on dire ça comme ça euh
qui qu'on alors ça se passe en
Méditerranée oui je citue jamais non il
y a pas c'est pas on peut penser c'est
la Méditerranée oui oui je crois qu'on
dit que c'est la Méditerranée à un
moment euh et on le retrouve mort dans
une grotte qu'on ne peut atteindre que
que en avigant hein camaréute oui oui
camaréute et donc ça c'est le
premier crime enfin qui qui qui existe
et puis il se trouve que le son fils est
ensuite enlevé son petit garçon oui le
petit garçon est ensuite qui s'appelle
Victor je crois est ensuite enlevé euh
alors on apprend que bah il gendre d'un
d'un homme politique célèbre dans dans
la région qui est un sénateur euh qui a
jamais eu d'enduie judiciaire mais enfin
qui est pas le plus honnête des des
desbul des politiciens oui c'est ça euh
et puis on apprend aussi qu'il pourrait
avir envie de se séparer de sa femme qu'
avait une une liaison avec une autre
femme dont on ne sait pas si tient pas
tu un peu un truc de prostitué hein de
prostitution elle tient un salon de
massage avec avec finition
comme comme il s'est dit et puis il
pourrait y avoir aussi un trafic de drog
enfin on va pas rentrer dans dans dans
tous les détails de de de l'intrigue euh
ce qui est intéressant c'est alors là
vous passez c'est un peu différent parce
que euh les autres qui avaient c'était
plutôt des tueurs en série oui euh là on
est plutôt on va dire dans dans le
trafic de drogue notamment hein il y a
un meurtre et deux un ou deux règlements
de compte c'est voà c'est très bien
comment vous chois
choisissez parce c'est toujours
intéressant dans l'écriture des polars
c'est comment comment ça commence quoi
comment comment comment c'est ce qu'il
faut savoir dès le début où on va alors
je suis désolé de répondre ça mais je ne
sais absolument pas où je vais quand je
démarre ah oui alors ça commence à
s'affiner c'est vrai que là je je je
viens de terminer le 4e
euh je commence à voir maintenant mais
en général je pars et je sais pas trop
où je vais partez d' vous partez d'un
par exemple là d'un crime voilà oui ou
d'un dialogue parce que que je j'écris
plus des romans de de personnages et
donc ça ça m'est plus facile et à partir
d'un dialogue effectivement après on va
rebondir crevette va être appelé sur une
scène de crime et cetera et cetera et je
vais construire mon histoire comme ça
d'accord oui c'est ce qui vous
c'est vrai que on le sent d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui les intrigues sont sont
intéressantes mais c'est vrai que ce qui
vous amuse le plus je crois dans
l'écriture c'est les personnage c'est
les c'est les il y a il y a des des des
jeux de mots des très mauvais jeux de
mots aff ça me rappelle d'ailleurs des
gens que j'ai beaucoup connu il y a
longtemps mais oui et et et non c'est
vrai enfin je devis relever quelques uns
mais euh et d'ailleurs il et alors à la
fin il y a un truc qui est très amusant
c'est les remerciments oui parce que je
est-ce que vous Z il y a des citations
deux où il y a hein c'est ça hein et les
remerciments c'est c'est beaucoup alors
Michel audiar évidemment mais beaucoup
de beaucoup de chanteurs Barbara la
Bachou Jacques brê George brassin je
cite je cite
oui je cite beaucoup de chansons pas
toujours pas que des bonnes d'ailleurs
hein mais principalement des bonnes
effectivement la moine des choses
c'était de les remercier pour comme je
le dis je crois c'est dans tantou comme
pour tous les bons moments qui qui m'ont
procuré qu'il me procur encore ouais et
ah oui c'est pas
je par exemple dis je vais y aller
alors ça j'ai jamais pu retrouver
les autrices ce sont deux femmes qui
avaient écrit ça j'avais j'avais vu ça
chez pivot il y a très longtemps et donc
c'était pour dire Dardar quoi avait fait
fémin cEIT pas pareil dard c'est heureux
mais c'était dard comme le D et donc
elle disait
c'est intéressant il y a qu'un
truc alors euh il c'est une petite
erreur à mon avis mais c'est c'est que
votre sénateur vous dites qu'il est
réélu pour 9 an maintenant c'est 6 ans
hein ça a
changé c'est pas c'est pas partière tous
les tous les 6 ans tous les 6 ans mais
ils sont pour 6 ans ils sont plus pour 9
ans autrefois c'était 9 ans mais ouais
bah oui mais alors ou mais c'est un
vieux sénateur
ça ça passe bien euh évidemment il y a
il y a tout ça il y a il y a tout aussi
toute la vie en province enfin de de
provincial c'est ce qui aussi ce qui
vous intéresse d'ailleurs c'est une
petite ville oui bah c'est bah c'est
très simn enfin c'est très SIM c'est
très inspiré par simnon en ce sens-l
sauf que simnon il lui se rendait sur
place il étudiait et cetera non là c'est
une petite ville lambda de province
suffisamment grande pour avoir un
commissariat pour avoir un hôpital ça on
va le voir dans le prochain et
suffisamment peti pour être à l'abri
de à l'abri d'une surpopulation de la
fureur de tout ce qu'on veut vous disez
les l'effet divers
non ça m'arrive surtout en é vous arrive
de pour vous aspirer non je je oui je
peux relever des choses je lu dis pas
systématiquement je je peux relever des
choses effectivement et alors et ces
deux héros ils sont comment ils
sont venus comment il comment ils sont
nés alors euh pourquoi crevette d'abord
je cherche là là là c'est c'est un
travail de recherche je me suis dit
c'est parmi les les milliers les
milliers de polarards qui sortent si tu
veux faire quelque chose et comme ils
ont tous un commissaire un commandant un
truc me faut quand même un prénom qui un
nom pardon qui qui se ressorte un peu
donc j'ai pensé à crevette comme
j'aurais pensé à autre chose à homard
peut-être Bacardi j'aime pas le Rome
pourtant c'est le Rome qui m'y a fait
penser simplement j'ai mis un C au lieu
d'en mettre deux ou deux je sais plus un
c'est voilà au lieu d'en mettre deux
voilà d'accord et les prénoms c'est Léon
et Eddie parce qu' dit est d'origine
italienne donc c'est pour ça
bacardis donc on peut imaginer quoi ils
onton une bonne soixantaine hein alors
crevette est plus jeune Eddie Baccardi a
60 65 ans crevette a plutôt la
cinquantaine plutôt la cinquantaine
d'accord il est assez beau mec il on dit
souvent ça mais en même temps on sent
que le type il a sans doute il aime bien
manger quoi enfin il boit bacardier beau
mec crevette je sais pas je je pourrais
pas pas vous pourriez pas les les
décrire physiquement mais moi je les
vois alors je les vois très bien non
crevette je pense beaucoup moi je bon je
je lis beaucoup simn mais j'ai également
adoré la série qui avait tourné Bruno
créer qui pour moi une des meilleurs et
j'ai j'ai beaucoup je me suis beaucoup
inspiré de la démarche du côté massif du
côté bouon enfin oui c'était c'est
meilleur Bruno Crémer que jean-
richichard quiard il y a pas de pour moi
il y a pas de comparaison à la fin le
pauvre il était un peu diminué c'est oui
puis c'est surtout que c'est quand même
très fidèle bien reconstitué c'est c'est
soigné comme reconstitution mais il y a
il y a il y a oui il y a eu maintenant a
quand même eu beaucoup de puis y a des
films magnifiques tiré de tiré de simnon
pas toujours de M de
simn deux là récemment oui oui
absolument un sur maigré et l'autre sur
un Sim oui absolument c'était oui oui
c'était le compte je crois ou qui qui
avait très envie de de de faire ça avec
avec maig euh un un un petit mot sur
votre parcours parce que c'est il est
ass typique alors euh on peut dire on se
connait depuis longtemps depis très de
trop longtemps depuis trop longtemps et
et et et quand je vous ai connu on était
très jeune et vous vouliez faire une vos
héros c'était quoi brassins BR ça l'IT
toujours d'ailleurs oui et et et vous
avez une guitare comme eux et vous
chantiez ouais et votre rêve c'était
voilà de faire une carrière dans la
chanson ouais absolument la chanson n'a
pas voulu de moi c'est çaen a pas fallu
de beaucoup mais bon c'est pas grave
après j'ai j'ai épousé une carrière
professionnelle beaucoup de gens alors
c'est là que c'est là que parce que vous
êtes s là non c'est amusant parce que
parce que au fond vous avez une vie
comme ça qui fait un une sorte de de de
CERC comme si vous étiez revenu à vos
premiers amours avec les avec la au fond
la création le le le domaine artistique
l'écriture absolument et vous avez une
vie de de haut fonctionnaire après vous
êtes directeur d'hôpital sous-préfet
sous-préfet j'ai j'étais détaché comme
lon crevette d'ailleurs dans le corps
des sous-préfets je suis j'ai terminé ma
carrière comme directeur d'hôpital
enfin sachant que c'est un grade c'est
pas forcément une chefferie
d'établissement com d'accord et et
comment ça comment c'est venu ça alors
vous es dit à un moment allez il faut
que j'arrête j'arrête les bêtises non
non non je
bon j'aime beaucoup le le service public
ça c'est c'est vrai c'est c'est c'est
c'est consubstantiel à à moi-même si
j'ose dire donc j'ai déroulé une
carrière c'est à l'époque o on pouvait
on le peut encore mais plus
difficilement on pouvait profiter d'un
ascenseur social via ou il av des
examens internes des des conours
internes voilà ouais qui pe permettait
de de progresser dans la dans la
fonction publique oui ou est-ce qu' a un
peu il y a si il y a un peu lese encore
le concours intern enfin les concours
internes de l'enat il y a le recrutement
exéri enfin c'est peut-être un peu plus
un peu plus coincé encore qu' y a eu la
réforme de l'enat qui va peut-être
changer un peu les choses mais enfin bon
et et donc voilà vous et et pendant
toutes ces années vous êtes étiez dans
les
préfectures par exemple vous disiez vous
avez continué à chanter par exemple
oui mais c'était vraiment en cercle
privé quoià il non pas il y avit pas de
concert la PR arrivé quand même il y a
une vingtaine d'années dans ma côté de
ma ville natale de de redonner un oui un
ou deux spectacles mais c'était
uniquement je dis pas que c'était sur
invitation mais cétait pour des amis
copains dans la ou d'accord et mais vous
aviez l'idée d'écrire
ben je j'écrivais des chansons parce que
c'était c'est beaucoup plus rapide c'est
beaucoup plus simple alors même si
brassin se dit que sa chanson elle va
durer il va remettre sur l'ouvrage et
cetera ah ben brass s'en sent bien que
c'est tellement travaillé
retravaillé le premier bouquin que j'ai
écrit avant d'écrire des polars j'ai
écrit des romans j'ai écrit des
nouvelles parce que la nouvelle c'était
c'était rapide aussi est-ce qu'il y a
justement pas une une frustration ça de
quand on quand on a écrit des des
chansons c'està dire des choses dont on
voit le résultat très vite alors ça peut
ça peut être quelques heures ça peut
être quelques jours enfin ça ça va
relativement vite en roman c'est long
c'est long et on s'aperçoit qu'il faut
tout il faut creuser sans arrêt sans ça
en 20 pages votre même policier voilà
c'est fini fin et ça c'est c'est dur non
c'est oui moi pour moi c'est très dur ou
oui ou vous vous avez des rites non non
écriture non vous le matin non j'en non
j'ai j'ai pas de rite comment dire sur
le le cadencement mais euh en revanche
les la première moitié du bouquin est
très très difficile et quand je sens que
je vais aller je vais pouvoir aller à la
fin là ça va beaucoup mieux je travaille
beaucoup plus il y a beaucoup de de de
de bouquins que vous abandonnez non en
général je je m'y accroche oui jusqu'au
bout vous pensez que l'idée est bonne
vous Tiz non c'est bien parce que c'est
vrai que parfois on peut on peut é crire
abandonner en se disant non finalement
ça ça marche pas c'est mais et le fait
d'avoir trouvé ces ces ces deux héros
évidemment ça je dis pas que ça facilite
la tâche mais mais il y a un point
d'encrage qui est fort quoi ah c'est
pour moi c'est beaucoup plus simple
effectivement et puis bon ils ont ils
ont trouvé chacun une compagne et puis
oui alors il y en a une qui qui est
médecin légiste russe voilà alors là il
est très embêté dans l'affaire des flau
noir parce que il y a il y a le conflit
russe enfin la guerre en Ukraine qui
arrive pu donc elle perd sa enfin sa
mère est très malade elle peut pas aller
la voir rentrer et en outre sur le lieu
de vacances qui par le procureur pour
aller
autopsier le premier le premier
meurtre donc elle est pas très contente
mais il toujours une question qu'on se
pose sur les auteurs de polar c'est que
euh est-ce qu'on écrit des polarards
pour pas tuer soi-même oh non non non
non non moi vraiment je si je pu me
permettre je vais mettre des guillemets
je me marre quand je les oui vous amusé
oui c'est bon on sent on le sent
d'ailleurs on le sent la lecture c'est
plus les Mau plus les jeux de mots sont
mauvais plus je suis content en quelque
sorte j'ai même osé dans le dans le
prochain maître mais je je l'ai pas dit
au lecteur trouvé j'ai mis deux ou trois
contrepéteries plus mauvaisees les unes
que les autres ah c'est
bien cherchez ah c'est très bien les
contre ben merci beaucoup Maurice
d'accord alors euh ben je rappelle ça
c'est le dernierin c'est le l'affaire
des flambeau noirs donc c'est celui dont
on a parlé avec le le meurtre d'un
patron de pêche et l'enlèvement de de
son fils c'est et puis
alors le premier céit tou mergo on les
trouve toujours C éditions Larman et
puis et puis entre les deux je l'ai
malheureusement pas apporté mais c'est
le secret des mages du Tridon rouge
voilà donc c'est des enquêtes de
crevette et bacard merci beaucoup c'est
[Musique]
moi